So we've gone through
a fair amount of code.
Let's go ahead, and put it all together
in our database_setup.py file.
Let me start with this
configuration code that goes at
the beginning of our file,
and put it where it belongs.
I can also take this code at the end,
and put it at the end of the file.
Next, let's put our two class
definitions, right where they belong.
Next, we need to add
our table information.
And finally, our mappers.
Putting all this code together,
should give us a Python file
that looks something like this.
So, if we navigate to the directory,
where our database_setup.py file live,
and run it using the Python command,
we should get something like this.
Looking in the same folder,
where we have our code,
we see a newrestaurantmenu.db file.
This is our empty database.
Now that we have an empty database,
let's figure out how to populate
it with some information.